[Música]
primer surfista peruano en ganar tres
títulos mundiales y los últimos
panamericanos en 2019
después de andar estos panamericanos
sentí el cariño de la gente y el cariño
de todos los peruanos más que nunca me
sentí orgulloso de representar a este
lindo país lo que me toca ahora es
quitarme esta medalla admirar la y
guardarla y les voy a contar por qué
este ha sido un camino largo un camino
muy difícil un camino de más de 30 años
yo comencé a correr tabla desde los 7
años de edad en huanchaco una caleta de
pescadores al norte de perú a mis amigos
y a mí nos gustaba mucho correr olas
siempre que veníamos del colegio o los
fines de semana nos metíamos al mar
todos los días y practicamos por horas
la gente cada vez que me veía me decía
piccolo corres muy bien y yo empecé a
creerme eso y me lo creí mucho
fue así que a los 12 años corrí mi
primer campeonato nacional en huanchaco
en mi playa en mi casa entrenaba todo el
día ahí y obvio queda en este campeonato
imagínense tener 12 años yo tenía el
pecho de este tamaño orgullosísimo de lo
que había hecho y dije mi próxima meta
tiene que ser un nacional entonces fue
así que viajé a lima y por primera vez a
competir en una competencia fuera de mi
playa estaba parado en la orilla del mar
esperando que comience la serie vi pasar
a los chicos de mi edad los vi entrar y
dije este campeonato lo ganó está
facilísimo
me metí remando por los 20 minutos que
dure que dura esa serie y adivinen que
me fue malísimo
no puede avanzar ese hit me sentí triste
no sabía si era una fue una buena idea
haber ido a ese campeonato no
ah y el deporte me comenzaba a enseñar
el camino no es como uno se lo imagina
estaba sentado en la orilla de la playa
recuerdo llorando y se acercó uno de mis
ídolos se acercó y me dijo piccolo no
llores siempre hay una segunda
oportunidad pero hay que trabajar para
eso con ese mensaje regresé a trujillo
entrené duro entrené mucho al siguiente
año
a esa misma playa y me encontré
nuevamente parado
en esa misma orilla
entrando a mi primera serie me fue bien
gane ese primera serie terminó el día y
terminé ganando todo el campeonato corrí
cuatro fechas más y salí campeón
nacional
otra vez orgullosísimo pero al parecer
no había aprendido muy bien la lección
porque dije mi próxima meta tiene que
ser un campeonato mundial
acaba de andar un nacional ok
con esa con esta decisión y muy seguro
me inscribí a mi primera competencia
internacional un clasificatorio para la
fecha del tour mundial me seguir
preparando llegó a esa fecha
os recuerdo que este campeonato lo
corrimos en huanchaco en mi playa una
playa que conocía le gané a muchos
competidores internacionales termine el
evento con el mejor puntaje de todo el
evento y con esto conseguir la
clasificación
al siguiente año 2012 el campeonato
mundial en china nuevamente me sentí
orgulloso de lo que había hecho se me
acercó una persona y me dijo piccolo te
felicito acabas de ganar este cambio ten
esta competencia pero yo creo que vas a
necesitar un entrenador hay que la
competencia siguiente va a ser muy
difícil yo lo miré pensé y dije pero que
está equivocado acabo de ganar es
nacional y acabo de ganar este
campeonato con el mejor puntaje si no
está fácil viaje a china
llegó el primer día del evento para ser
la primera serie bien la segunda serie
bien me comenzaba a querer mucho más era
posible ganar ese campeonato pero en la
tercera serie me tocó con el actual
campeón del mundo en ese entonces
lo miré me metía al mar corrí esos 20
minutos y adivinen qué fue la peor
paliza de mi vida realmente no estuve ni
hacía cerca de poder alcanzarlo ni
siquiera le hice la pelea
una vez más el mar me enseñaba que en
sus olas el camino no es como uno se lo
imagina que para afrontar nuevos retos
realmente uno se tiene que preparar
camino al hotel recordé la frase que me
dijo una vez la persona que yo admiraba
que siempre hay una segunda oportunidad
con esto a esto se sumaba que haber
avanzado hasta esta tercera ronda me
daba la clasificación para el siguiente
año
de regreso a perú me acorde
de este amigo que se acercó y me dijo
que necesitaba un entrenador realmente
tenía razón
fue una playa totalmente distinta a lo
que yo estaba acostumbrado correr
las condiciones del mar totalmente
distintas a las que corría todos los
días
fue así que decidí llegar a perú buscar
un entrenador y comenzar de nuevo
le conté a mi entrenador lo que había
pasado cómo me sentí los errores que
había cometido y decidí contarle no no
mi experiencia buena sino la experiencia
mala con la que no puede avanzar más en
china decidimos cambiar la tabla cambiar
la pista cambiar la acera cambiar la
ropa el baño con la que corría todo con
con todo lo que está acostumbrado a
correr decidimos dejarlo a un lado
porque sólo servía para las condiciones
de perú pero no para las de china
entonces hicimos todo un plan
estratégico nuevo de entrenamiento y
tuve que adaptarme a un cambio y uno de
los cambios fue no tener un entrenador
necesitaba la guía de una persona una
persona que me guíe y me ayude a darme
cuenta de los errores que yo cometía
porque según yo todas las olas las
corría increíble pero no fue así
íbamos a entrenar todos los días en las
mañanas y por las tardes observamos los
vídeos
cada vez que yo salía de correr le decía
un entrenador que tal esa ola buena si
pero realmente al ver los vídeos me daba
cuenta de muchos errores y el entrenador
me supo guiar de una manera muy buena de
una manera adecuada
fue así
qué
en el 2013 antes del campeonato mundial
en china se iba a celebrar en huanchaco
en mi playa en mi casa una fecha del
tour mundial por equipos y vi la
oportunidad de poder poner a mi país en
la cima del mundo y dije este campeonato
voy a tener que ganarlo por mi país
había entrenado mucho estaba muy
preparado
una semana antes del evento en uno de
los entrenamientos cogió una bola grande
no puede salir a tiempo y la bola me
cayó en la rodilla sentí mucho dolor no
pude salir del mar solo mis amigos me
dieron y mi entrenador me llevé los me
llevó al hospital
después de unas horas se acercó el
doctor y me dijo que tenía el ligamento
el ligamento lateral interno de la
rodilla parcialmente roto
me sentí muy triste pensé que no podía
correr más ese campeonato está muy
desanimado pero sentía que podía mover
la pierna entonces se me ocurrió
preguntarle al doctor doctor no habrá
una posibilidad de poder correr este
campeonato el doctor me miró salió me
quedé con mi esposa y mi entrenador
y al cabo de unos minutos regresó el
doctor y me dijo mira si hacemos terapia
estos cinco días que faltan para que
comience el evento podemos ayudar de
bajar el dolor y mejorar la movilidad de
la pierna y puedes correr ese campeonato
yo abrir los ojos y en mi cabeza dije
mismo voy a poder correr
pero no todo era bonito el doctor me
dijo vas a poder correr el campeonato
pero vas a pues vas a correr un riesgo y
esto implicaría que el ligamento se
termine de romper y no puedas correr
durante seis meses
el doctor se fue hablé con mi entrenador
hablé con mi esposa
y decidimos afrontar esta
responsabilidad juntos y decidimos que
si correr y ese campeonato
llegó el campeonato y recuerdo estar
parado ese primer día en la orilla del
mar antes de entrar a mi hit con un poco
de dolor en la pierna uno
entré a correr la primera serie y
después de cinco días me encontraba en
las instancias finales del evento estaba
a punto de entrar a mi semifinal si
pasaba esa serie estaba en la final y
podría
competir por este título mundial para mi
país
aunque
físicamente aunque mentalmente estaba
intacto físicamente ya no puede seguir
más la rodilla no aguanto mi pierna no
puedo más terminé en el hospital con la
pierna hinchada y con mucho dolor la
buena noticia fue que el ligamento no se
me rompió solo tenía dolor y un poco de
hinchazón
eso no me desanimo eso me dio mucho
coraje y mucho valor porque
a los 4 meses a los siguientes 4 meses
tenía la oportunidad de seguir
preparándome y de seguir recuperando esa
lección porque venía el campeonato
mundial en china
llegó un fin de año y me tocó otra vez
estar parado en esa misma playa
en el 2012 no puede pasar gracias al
campeón mundial
entre mi primer hit puede pasar la
primera ronda la segunda la tercera la
cuarta la quinta y la sexta
el séptimo día me encontré parado otra
vez en la orilla del mar al costado del
actual campeón del mundo ese campeón que
no me dejó avanzar en esa primera ronda
tome aire perece de mesa en esa frase
que me dijeron una vez que siempre hay
una segunda oportunidad y sentí que
realmente esta era estaba preparado para
afrontar lo que venía entre
no comencé la serie muy bien estaba un
poco nervioso obviamente por tener al
campeón del mundo al costado
pasaron 15 minutos y faltaban 5 para
terminar la serie estaba segundo todo el
tiempo no había forma de pasar al
campeón del mundo no comencé con una
estrategia bien comencé a agarrarla sola
muy rápido no busqué la adecuada no suma
los puntos necesarios necesitaba 9
puntos de un posible 10 para poder pasar
al campeón del mundo
fue así que decidí aplicar la estrategia
de mi entrenador
era esperar la mejor o la mejor ola
aunque no sabíamos si esta ola de
llegaría nunca supe si esa ola o sea no
supe si en ese momento esa ola llegaría
o no llegaría simplemente decidí esperar
y confiar en que esta ola llegaría
porque así como en la vida el mar el mar
es muy impredecible
faltaban dos minutos y no llegaba a la
ola faltaba un minuto y no llegaba la
ola faltaron 40 segundos y vi llegar esa
ola la reme con todas mis fuerzas me
paré en ella y sentí que esa era corrí
la ola lo mejor que pude y fue una ola
tan buena y tan larga que terminé parado
en la orilla del mar
sabiendo que había hecho un buen trabajo
pero ya el resultado no dependía de mí
dependía de los jueces
cerré los ojos respire hondo pensé que
habían pasado horas pero realmente
habían pasado segundos y escuché decir
la última ola de color azul 9.7 el nuevo
campeón del mundo
piccolo clemente realmente
me sentí orgulloso por lo que había
hecho
entendí que para afrontar nuevos retos y
tomar decisiones hay que prepararse
y hay que hacer
muy conscientes de las decisiones que
uno toma entre el 2013 y el 2018 de
seguir preparando mucho me mantuve
siempre entre los mejores entre los 8
mejores del mundo nunca baje la guardia
y siempre me preparaba pensando en que
en algún momento llegaría la oportunidad
de volver a representar a mi país fue
así en el 2018 me enteré el 2019 se
celebrarían los juegos panamericanos
una oportunidad de poner a mi país en la
cima del mundo llegaron los juegos
panamericanos y recuerdo haber estado
parado en la orilla del mar para entrar
a mi serie
dije estoy preparado
en real mar y todo el evento correcto a
mí series de la mejor manera fue así que
terminé con el mejor puntaje de todo el
campeonato 1 19.83 imposible 20
entendí que es bueno celebrar nuestros
logros de tener un diploma de ganar una
medalla de tener un campeón en un
campeonato mundial pero esto no nos
puede quitar el foco no nos puede hacer
pensar que no tenemos nada más que
aprender en la vida siempre se aprende
algo nuevo la vida es un aprendizaje
constante lo que me toca hacer ahora
así como
tengo este título que es una medalla que
me costó mucho lograrla lo que me toca
hacer ahora es guardar esta medalla y
salir o buscar una próxima gracias
[Aplausos]